Throughout this unit, we've been working with quadratic equations. Now, let's
check out quadratic inequalities. A quadratic inequality looks a lot like a
quadratic equation, except instead of an equal sign, we'll either have a
greater than symbol, a less than symbol, a less than or equal to symbol, or a
greater than or equal to sign. When we solve a quadratic inequality, we want to
find all the values of x that make this statement true. In this case, we want
any x value. So that way, when we evaluate this side, it's greater than 0. Now,
we have an inequality here. So we know there's going to be more than one
solution. In fact, there's going to be an infinite number of solutions. So to
find the range of all possible values, let's start by finding which x values
make this statement equal to 0. So, what two values of x make this statement
equal 0. Write the smaller number here and the larger one here.